- Hi, how's everybody doing?
Exciting. Exciting to be here.
So, this is very ambitious.
Over the next 20 minutes,
this is a lightning talk.
we're gonna cover roughly a
half century of computing,
but we'll try to go as fast as possible.
So, we'll start off and we're
gonna try to end with AI.
So, we'll start and end with AI.
So, first of all, show of hands,
anybody recognize any of these logos up
on the screen right now?
Show of hands, anybody?
Okay, I mean, this is a
definitely a SaaS conference,
so I would imagine so.
These are products that have represented
the best of what SaaS has offered us over
the last 15, 20 years.
And obviously this is how we
went from spreadsheets sitting
on our local computers to software
that could run in the cloud,
cloud native with the scale,
the safety, the speed of
cloud behind us, right?
To give us auditability, transparency,
scalability, security.
And that's been a great journey.
And what I call that,
I call that SaaS 1.0,
but there's a flip side of it,
and the flip side is that we
have now gotten to a place
where all of these disparate tools
have created their own
rigid schemas that define
at the department level
what good looks like.
So, they have these schemas,
whether it's an opportunity,
whether it's a ticket,
whether it's an incident,
perhaps it's an event or a case.
Each of these respective department tools
have created their own
terminology, their own glossary.
And that glossary comes to really define
how we use these products
and how we do our daily jobs.
And there's something about that
that actually gives us an
opportunity to think further
to say, "How would AI revisit this?"
If we were to look at
where we go from here,
from SaaS 1.0 to SaaS 2.0,
what would it look like?
And so, again, as I promised,
I wanna start stepping
back and saying, well,
how have the greats over
the generations of computing
that we've come to see,
how have they tackled this problem?
So, a couple of logos up there,
obviously you probably recognize them.
What have they done so incredibly well?
Well, first thing what they did
was they catered to the builders.
They created the right
separation of concerns
so that there were a lot of problems
that could be solved at
scale so that developers
and great minds,
entrepreneurs could do great
things on top of the platform
that was built.
And this was great,
because if you remember before
the cloud really came to be,
there were a lot of people
that were reading books
about client server
architectures and JSON and APIs
and saying, "You know what?
I can do that. I can do that at home.
I can do that at the workplace,
and I'm gonna start setting that up."
You set up a Linux server,
before you know it,
you've got an IT closet
full of servers and racks,
and it's serving real use cases.
Maybe you're handling transactions online,
but at some point you realize
that you gotta do security patches
and you gotta do security updates,
and you've gotta do deployments
and you gotta have zero downtime
and you gotta make sure
that the hard drives
are still working, and
this became a problem.
And that's where a lot
of these tools started
to come together,
and they started to create
the right abstractions for us
to do a great job.
And so, it's similar
to what we're starting
to see here as well.
What we're seeing is the
fact that everything starts
to look really easy to begin with, okay?
So, I wanna start off by saying, look,
I got this LLM at my disposal,
and this LLM is obviously
exceedingly easy to use,
conversationally, and it can
do some really great things.
It can classify, cluster,
prioritize, summarize, synthesize,
it can do all of these things,
and I can put this to work
to solve real problems.
I can solve real problems
towards specific conversations,
specific tickets, and down
the list, and I can do this.
But what happens is you can start
to increasingly get to a place
where you get back to that
really messy IT closet.
And we've started to see
this in the market now.
You're starting to see situations,
you got headlines like this,
I don't know, show of hands,
people who actually saw the
story, maybe heard of the story,
companies that went out
and said, "You know what?
We're gonna stop using humans
to do problem A, problem B,
problem C, we've got this covered.
We're gonna do it using agents.
It's that simple."
But it wasn't really that simple, was it?
And it's six months later,
it's a new headline,
same company, new headline.
No, actually, we're gonna
need those humans again.
And so, a little bit of
this has been happening,
and why is that?
And it's because we have to
really start to understand
what are the right abstractions
and where are the areas of opportunity
and what are those separation of concerns?
And of course, as we figure that out,
we're starting to see headlines
like this where MIT reports,
and I know many of you
have probably seen this
on your LinkedIn feeds and so on,
where we talk about 95%
of these pilots failing.
What does that really mean?
And I think what it
means, among other things,
is the fact that you not only
need a frontier model layer,
but you need to really
think about the data layer.
You need to think about how
the data becomes accessible
and in whose hands?
So, access provisioning makes sense.
You have to start to
think about replication.
You have to start to think
about data sanitization,
and that's just the data layer.
You gotta think on top of
that about provisioning,
auditability, agents and
workflows, repeatability.
You have to start to think
about end to end use cases.
How do you serve real use cases
and customer success,
customer support, field sales,
development productivity,
project management?
These are real problems.
And until and unless you are willing
to not just think about the data layer
and build a prototype on top of it,
when you get ready to actually
look at the data layer
and the operational layer
and the application layer,
that's when you're ready for production.
And so, it's a journey.
So, we have to think about that and say,
"Well, where are we headed?"
The reality is there's
such tremendous momentum
because people believe
that there's a huge
opportunity here with AI,
particularly agentic AI,
particularly conversational AI.
And so, money's already being spent.
I'm sure some of you go
back to your workplace
and you see your leadership asking you,
"How are you taking advantage of AI?"
And money's being spent, holdbacks,
budget being shifted from headcount,
perhaps over to making
decisions around buying tools
or AI products and saying,
"how are we becoming more productive?
How are we reducing customer
effort or employee effort?
How are we improving
customer satisfaction?"
These are real questions
that are being asked,
and we have to figure
out how we get to answers
that really help us in the long term.
And so, I'm gonna take us
further back from cloud and say,
"Well, how did we get
started with computers
five decades ago, six decades ago
when we had those behemoths
sitting in our workspaces,
workstations, mainframes?
How did we get to where we are today?"
And the reality is we started
off, it was expensive,
it was onerous, and it wasn't
really easy to figure out
how this all makes sense,
but we figured it out.
We decided that to go
big, we had to go small.
We had to create an operational
system, an operating system,
and we had to start to figure out
how to build more programs on
top of it, build work groups,
and make things shareable,
and make things more use case-driven
and create a user experience.
And so, that was our ticket
to the kind of expansion
that we saw in the decades to follow.
So, if we start to think
about that and say,
"Well, what does that teach us?"
What it teaches us is that if
we build the right paradigm,
you can have tremendous purpose
by thinking about the hardest problems
by building on top of those paradigms.
And that's what we've done.
We got more productive, more efficient,
we got more creative.
And that's the huge
opportunity that's existed,
not just when the mainframes came
to becoming more workstations for us,
but then when the desktop
came out, when cloud came out,
and again here with AI,
that's the same opportunity that we have.
It's an opportunity for us to
define the operating system
and then to figure out how
we use and develop that
to become more productive,
efficient, and more creative.
And so, how do we bring
that computer mindset to AI?
How do we bring an operating
system to the forefront here?
So, let's just think about it and say,
"What would it look like?
What would the dream computer look like?"
The dream computer would be able
to take all your critical data
and all your critical integrations
and bring them to your
most important surfaces.
That would be the
computer that you'd want.
It would be a computer that
did not create false boundaries
between your opportunities
and your incidents,
or your tasks and your sessions,
or your issues and your
cases and your events.
It would really understand
and respect all of it,
and it wouldn't think
that any of this information was foreign.
It's all part of your business.
These are all departments that are serving
the same customer.
They're working towards building
the same set of products.
Am I right? So, that's where we wanna go.
And so, how do we get there?
Well, what we've thought
about is to create a product
that does just that, and we
actually call it a Computer.
It's called Computer, Computer by DevRev.
And so, it's exactly that.
It brings your most critical data,
your most critical integrations
to all your most important surfaces,
whether that's at the
workstation, on the desktop,
in a customer help support center,
in a portal, on your website,
perhaps on the mobile device,
wherever you need it,
Computer is there and it's multiplayer,
so it's not just there for you,
it's there for your team
and your organization,
and it's also there for your customer.
And there's some really hard
problems behind the scenes
that need to be solved to
do this really, really well.
First of all, you need to understand
how to unify information.
And unifying information is
not just about being able
to export data.
That's not what it's about.
It's not about taking
data from here to there.
That's not the problem to solve.
This is about creating
memory for agents and AI,
for computer, really.
And this is about understanding
how to bring information
in a near real time bidirectional way,
because if it's bidirectional
in near real time,
you can actually take
actions on that information
and actually have it
reflect back in the systems
where the information originated,
so you can continue to coexist
with the rest of your infrastructure,
with the rest of your long tail of IT.
It has to coexist.
And for that reason alone,
it needs to be bi-directional
and near real time.
And it can't just bring in the data,
it's gotta bring in all
the metadata, right?
It's gotta understand the metadata
so it knows what the other
options are in the dropdown menu.
And it needs to understand
what the other radio button
selection of possibilities were,
because how else would
you actually take action
if you don't understand
the field dependencies
and the access provisions
and the selection criteria
and the variables at bay?
So, that's where you wanna be.
You wanna be in a place
where you can bidirectionally
sync information
and understand the schema
and the access provisions
so that you can respect all
of that as you create a system
that can search, give you
answers, and of course,
take action on that as well.
And of course, when you
bring it into memory,
memory is gonna have to
handle both long-term
and short-term context.
It's gotta be able to give
you the most fast, accurate,
and hyper-personalized answers.
That's the only way to
create a personal computer.
And of course, you can't just
do that by mimicking the data
as it exists in these disparate systems.
You need to understand how to
connect data between the work
that you do, your persona,
the customers you serve,
and the product you create.
And so, this information,
these inner relationships
need to be understood deeply.
And of course, if you're
gonna do all that,
you're gonna need a series
of foundational services
on top of it.
These are simple but powerful
foundational services.
You gotta be able to search.
And of course,
what we know is that as we
have gone deeper in search,
it's a deep problem.
You've gotta be able to do it at scale.
You need to understand
not just the syntax,
the keywords, but the semantics,
and you gotta enrich this information.
It's gotta be able to
understand the deep annotations,
the links between work and opportunities
and customers and entities and identities.
It's gotta understand
that really, really well.
And it's gotta be fast
at the scale of GPUs.
So, that's where we want to be.
And of course, it has to be able
to contextualize all the
answers based on who you are,
so you're not just giving the
same information to everybody.
It's gotta be unique and personalized.
And of course, it's
gotta have a data layer
that's well suited to agentic AI.
Agentic AI can't be built effectively
on top of the data layer that we use
to build client server architectures
or to build traditional
client or cloud systems.
It has to be a data layer that
is native to conversational
as much as it is a more
conventional surface.
And so, SQL, what's old is new again.
SQL is something that's grounded in fact,
it's easy to advocate for,
it's grounded in facts,
so you can actually audit
it, you can trace it,
you can acknowledge it, you can permit it,
and so you can conversationally
access your information
and you know that the answer that you got
was based on real facts
because you have the
understanding of the SQL
that was working behind the scenes
to actually provide that information.
And you can then take that
and in a more traditional way,
access it to create a
graph or a dashboard,
or to share that information
with somebody else
who can do more intelligence on top of it.
And so, this is the most
universal way for you
to communicate with your
information in traditional ways,
but also in more conversational ways.
So, that's what the future looks like.
It's not abandoning SQL,
it's actually embracing it
as a unified data layer.
And of course, you also have to say yes
to not just the data in memory,
but the data outside of memory, right?
So, just like computers
had access to the internet,
so do these agentic computers,
these computers have access to via MCP,
so you can actually access
tools from around the world
and have plans that reflect not just
the information inside your memory,
but all the information
outside it as well.
So, this is what a modern
computer looks like.
It's built on all of these engines,
the powerful engine of search
that is both syntactic and semantic
and powered by LLMs, but also SQL,
the ability to ground facts,
but be conversational as
much as you are conventional.
Dashboards and conversational
at the same time.
Of course, MCP as well.
And that's just on the access
for searches and answers.
But to take actions, you need
to be able to build agents
and upscale agents,
because we're not gonna be
able to create thousands
and hundreds of agents.
Who's gonna name them and
who's gonna address them?
It's too difficult.
You gotta have a thoughtful mechanism
to actually upskill these agents.
And these agents cannot be
put in everybody's hands
to go create and upskill agents
for the rest of the company.
That's not gonna work.
You have to allow for citizen development.
That means the ability for people
to actually upskill an agent,
perhaps just for themselves,
or perhaps for their team,
maybe the department,
and just maybe for the
entire organization.
But it has to work within these scopes.
You have to allow for skills
and agents to manifest
at the personal level so
that people can have autonomy
to create the type of automations
they need for themselves,
perhaps for their teams,
and then maybe for
their companies as well.
And of course, the same reflects
back into the enterprise.
You can't have the same
agents actually advocating
across your customers for everybody.
It could be different and
unique for every brand,
for every region, for every channel.
It's not a one-size-fits-all.
And so, you need to be able
to not only upskill agents
and do this in a way that's scalable,
one that allows you to create skills
or maybe borrow them from a marketplace,
or maybe create them and
define them in a no code way,
but also to deploy them
in really responsible ways
at the brand, at the region,
at the channel level,
or at the team level
or personally perhaps.
And so, that's what we're looking for.
And of course, putting it all together,
computer has to be able
to answer questions
by accessing all of this information.
So, you're able to answer
questions like the one over here,
and it's able to rattle through
all of these tools you use,
whether it's a Jira or a
Notion, it doesn't matter.
It's able to access that information,
provide an answer that's fully cited
so you can continue with your work.
And of course, it not only
synthesizes information,
but it's gotta be able to do
some reasoning on top of it.
And so, not only do you want
it to synthesize information,
but you want it to actually create a plan
and to reason about the information
so you actually get an opinion,
one that leverages the innate
ability for frontier models
to cluster and synthesize, prioritize,
and classify information.
That's super important as well.
So, here you can see that not
only are we getting an answer
that's grounded in the
information across our enterprise,
but it actually gives you some
opinions, of course, again,
grounded in facts that are fully cited.
And of course, you could
follow up those questions
with real questions like,
"What are the action items?"
And it'll actually tell you.
And of course, not only are
you able to unify information,
not only are you able to use planning
and synthesis to get reasonable responses,
you can actually take actions.
So, in this particular case,
not only am I asking questions,
I'm actually asking for a
meeting to be scheduled.
And this is the real sort of synthesis
of where this is going, right?
You're gonna have the ability
to unify your information,
have a teammate that can
actually maybe help you reason
about what needs to happen.
And if you believe it,
if you agree or disagree,
you can ask follow up questions
with the same level of context,
and finally take actions
to maybe create work,
create opportunities, or
perhaps schedule work,
what have you.
So, these are sort of
some of the examples.
And just putting it all together,
ultimately it has to help
you work more productively,
faster than ever before.
And so, that's where we are headed.
We have to be able to ask questions like,
"What is our travel policy?"
And not only are we expecting an answer
that is grounded in the
information that exists,
it is the exact information
that makes sense for who I am
and the department that I
belong to, so on and so forth.
And I can ask follow up questions and say,
"What about this other region?"
Not for myself,
but I wanna know what the
travel policy looks like
in that other region.
And it'll actually tell you
because it understands
that that's not the region
that's native to you.
And these are the kinds of experiences
that we will come to expect
from these modern computers.
So, just to kind of recap, again,
these are not systems that are gonna work
at the boundaries of departments.
I mean, they may help
you in your departments,
but they have to be able to
go beyond those departments
to say, "You know what?
I'm not just a computer
for your support team.
I'm a computer that
also works equally well
for the people that are
building the software,
people who are working
closely with the customers,
and people who are creating deep insights
so that we understand where to go next."
It has to work for everybody.
It cannot create false
boundaries between agents
and microservices or applications.
It has to coexist with all of that.
So, just to keep it really
simple a little bit,
you can find us at Booth 1204.
So, if you're excited and
don't know where to go next,
1204, Booth 1204, near Theater
2 is where we're located.
Our founders, Dheeraj Pandey and Manoj,
previously of Nutanix Fame,
left in 2020 to start this company.
So, we've got a forward deploy team,
Applied AI help you with this journey,
and of course, we do a lot of workshops.
And DevRevU helps you with understanding
how to embrace this world
as we make this transition
from SaaS 1.0 to SaaS 2.0.
Beyond that, a little bit about customers.
We've got hundreds of
customers, we've got partners.
You see some of those logos,
I'm sure you recognize those.
And of course, fully
compliant, GDPR-ready,
lots of money raised, so on and so forth.
Thank you so much for your time.